what about
the role of jealousy something you also
written about in a relationship
is uh
is that a feature a bug
you cut you started to speak about it
but is
is it good to be
jealous of your partner inside of a
relationship how does it go wrong
how
the pros and cons so uh so i've written
a whole book on this uh called the
dangerous passion um why jealousy is as
necessary as sex and love
and
uh i think that uh
one
cut at your question is that um a
moderate so first of all i think it's
it's a feature not a bug in in most
cases so in the in the sense that
you you have to have an adaptation that
is sensitive to threats to a valued
relationship
okay because
and i think i alluded to this earlier
that just because you're in a
relationship and you're in a
relationship with a desirable partner
doesn't mean that
you know you've finished solving the
problems of mating that you need to
solve because there are threats from the
outside so mate poachers people who
try to lure your partner away for either
a sexual encounter or a more committed
romantic relationship
and then there's also dissatisfaction
within the relationship so your partner
might become tempted to be sexually
unfaithful or romantically unfaithful or
emotionally unfaithful
and so and so we need
humans
with the evolution of long-term pair
bonding we need adaptations to guard
the relationship and be sensitive to
threats to the relationship
and i think jealousy is one of those i
think that's it's a key one
and now
um
that i think that uh there are a variety
of benefits to it but also a variety of
um costs or downsides to jealousy
because we know that jealousy
male sexual jealousy is the leading
cause of spousal abuse and spousal
violence physical physical violence
probably emotional violence as well or
psychological
violence uh and so that's why i call it
the dangerous passion it's it's it's a
necessary emotion
but it is also a dangerous emotion
um leads to homicide
um you know leads to uh and
i've studied also homicidal ideation uh
which is intersects with this topic in
that
men sometimes women to a lesser degree
develop homicidal ideation about people
who are trying to poach their mates or
who do poach their mates
successfully poach their mates so what
jealousy does is it is it alerts you to
a threat to the relationship and it
motivates um
checking out the source of the threat
how threatening is this so think people
tend to increase vigilance
of their partner in the modern world
includes you know hacking into their
cell phone or computer
monitoring them
sometimes stalking them
but also can include
positive things so it might be that so
one trigger of jealousy is is is a
direct threat to the relation but
there's another more subtle
trigger of jealousy which is a mate
value discrepancy so usually when people
mate there's they they assort or pair up
on overall mate values so the in the
american
10 point scale the eights tend to pair
up with the eighths the sixes with the
sixes
the tens with the tens and the ones with
the ones american is there other out of
the scales
uh i i i wonder if the miracle systems
well there's a binary i just don't find
it with zero one
sorry go ahead okay i know yeah the
eighth pairs with the age seven yeah
yeah so in general but there are errors
in mate selection you kind of alluded to
the that issue earlier that sometimes
people make errors errors inmate
selection which they do so sometimes you
think this person is well matched on
mate value but they're not but then
things change
so a let's say uh they're the same you
have two sixes and then all of a sudden
the woman's career takes off
all of a sudden she's
you know uh getting promotion she's uh
uh acquiring wealth she's attracting
men who are of a different
mate value than she previously did well
that triggers jealousy in the guy even
if she swears she's going to be totally
loyal and she has no signs of leaving or
no signs of infidelity
a mate value discrepancy is going to
trigger jealousy
now what can it do well it can do
in the broadest sense people can do two
classes of things they can do cost
inflicting things or benefit providing
things so the the man in that situation
might
say okay i need to devote more attention
to my partner i need to up my game when
it comes to resource acquisition i need
to
lavish more
attention and gifts on her and so
there's a whole suite of benefit
provisioning things that can help to
reduce that mate value discrepancy
and then there's all also cost
inflicting things that and and and
humans unfortunately do both
both sets of things
yeah i there's also this uh maybe that's
love i notice um
the people i especially
love or have a connection to
romantically or otherwise there's a
feeling like i don't deserve you
so
with friends with so on like i mean i
tend to think that about almost
everything which is why it's a strong
signal when i don't feel it that way
which is like i can't i'm how lucky am i
to have this
uh and that's a good that's a that's a
weird illusion of inflation of value or
something like uh i think that the
positive effect of that is makes what
motivates me to be better
i guess on this 110 skill to be higher
and you just sort of kind of
have to either like it's a nice feature
that your mind sees others that you have
affection towards as
higher value and it forces you to have
that like i'm a person that experiences
jealousy and that forces me to be better
yeah i get my [ __ ] together yeah well
and i think that the the um sometimes
the best relationships are when both
people feel lucky to be with the other
person yes exactly it's balanced that
way and then that's when you in terms of
jobs in terms of going to the gym all
those kinds of things
and um yeah so a little bit of jealousy
i have a discussion with those people i
always wonder
there's people in relationships where
like no no
there's no they never experienced
jealousy i wonder what that's like
because they're very successful
relationships but
and i always wonder you know i'm
currently single so i always doubt that
i know what the hell i'm doing at all
uh but i i'm definitely somebody that
experiences jealousy and kind of enjoys
jealousy
um like
a little bit
of like missing to me that's like you're
missing the other person yeah well
longing for the other person and here's
another
interesting wrinkle that i also talk
about in the book is uh sometimes people
intentionally evoke jealousy in their
partner
uh and i think that's also a kind of
testing of a bond uh kind of issue yeah
so and
especially women but i think both sexes
uh interpret a total absence of jealousy
as a sign that their partner is not
sufficiently committed to them or
sufficiently in love with them
so if you like to say i don't know if
you you're you go to a party with your
partner and then you
leave the room for some reason you come
back and your partner is passionately
kissing someone else and doesn't bother
you at all
um that might be a cue to the partner
that well maybe you're not very in love
with that person or not very committed
to them